and i think writers should challenge
themselves like what's hard for you
make yourself do that thing
make yourself do it even if you're
scared of doing it
when you were writing a story what type
of structure do you use most often
hero's journey that's that's i use that
structure probably the most because um
again it helps me kind of track the
emotions of my character what are they
afraid of what do they want um how do
they have to kind of face that fear
um i'm writing something now
and i decided to do something i should
probably not have done which is like
i'm gonna go free i'm gonna i'm gonna
try to just start writing this thing and
i just i
i just barfed it out which is which is
actually good for me because i need to
actually do that because i tend to be
over here in my left brain a lot and so
i i barfed this thing out and it's like
it's like 70 pages i'm not even really
sure what it is except it is a detective
themed thing
um but i read through it again and now
i'm going oh okay
i think this is what it is like this one
little part over here
that's where
like the the juice lies um and so now
i'm taking that little juicy thing and
going okay
how can i sort of um approach the
rewrite with more of a map
and a view to kind of now what i think
it's about
and so usually i just i i make a very
loose outline
it's not detailed it really just says
kind of like the major action beats you
know like what happens in the inciting
incident or the call to adventure and
whether the person pushes away from it
out of fear and then what happens next
to kind of pull them in
but i want to leave it kind of not not
detailed because then that leaves things
for me to discover when i'm writing
so is it harder for you to not be
organized and invested in structure
yes it's very hard for me to be free
that's why i think i gave myself that
challenge of just
pat let
step away from the outline
step away
and i needed to kind of just go blah you
know and um when i did that i actually
found really interesting things
happening that i didn't expect and again
that's where i found that little spark
that was like oh this is this is what
it's about um
so yeah for me and i think writers
should challenge themselves like what's
hard for you
make yourself do that thing
make yourself do it even if you're
scared of doing it you know make
yourself do it and then
get more comfortable with it because
there's something in there
that's scaring you and that's good
you need to go there you need to go into
your own approach to the cave as a
writer you know um
so i work with a lot of people who are
writing kind of um
memoir
book books i work with authors as well
and a lot of the times they're like i
think i'm going to change this
so that it's not about the person so
that they when they and i'm like you
know what
this is your draft no one's going to
read it but you
write every single thing that happened
write the truth because if you're
holding back
we're going to know
that you're being untruthful with us now
after you get out this version where
everything the truth is everything
everybody did is on the page
then you can go back and modulate and
figure out but you have to tell the
truth you know and
if you were writing a script that is
based on experience and you find
yourself going i don't want to write
that scene
you got it you got to go there
you know that's the scene
that's what your movie's about and
you're afraid to go there because like
there's something in there that you just
don't want to look at or you know yeah
and so for a a right-brained writer
who's messy and chaotic and everything's
sort of based on intuition then what
would scare them is probably structure
rules
numbered sequence you know right and and
i've worked with a lot of right-brained
writers you know and it's always it's
just a matter of usually they don't they
it's not like they do it 180 and
suddenly become like i'm have detailed
outlines usually it's just getting them
to a place
that is comfortable for them
to organize something so that they don't
get lost in the weeds you know their
right brain is their strength it's like
their superpower but it can also lead
them into the darkness and down tangents
and out into the woods and then they
don't know how to get back and oh my god
where's the flashlight so
you know helping them find something
that's comfortable in terms of
organization
but not too detailed you know um
and sometimes it's even just a matter of
talking through the character's
emotional journey and how they change
that gives them enough in their head to
kind of guide their writing as their
writing so maybe they don't even write
an outline they just kind of talk it
through
so that they kind of know where they're
going
you know
wouldn't know anything about it yeah is
that your i i'm your right brain yeah
yeah tried and true yeah yeah
check out the hero's journey okay yeah i
love um the interview that uh bill
moyers did with um joseph
it's so excellent and and
he just um the two of them together were
just a great team oh yeah yeah in terms
of uh the interview yeah that's a great
that's a great piece of i'm so glad they
recorded it right for posterity wouldn't
you say that if writers and filmmakers
follow these structures that their films
will be predictable you know that's
often something we get in our comments
yes and well this is why
hollywood produces
you know these formulaic movies
yes
that's always the danger
that's always the danger and you know
when you're watching a formulaic movie
you know
when you know exactly what's going to
happen in the climax on
10 minutes in
you know that that movie is gonna
fulfill
those expectations right
so
there's a couple of ways to approach
that idea of cliche and predictability
um if you're writing you know the
predictability doesn't just lie along
structure lines it also lies along genre
lines that certain genres hold have
conventions
that become familiar patterns right
and so um the trick is
to look at these forms whether it's a
structural form like the hero's journey
or three-act structure as a form and not
a formula
that it's just there to give you some
landmarks to help work through you know
the story with your character
um and then if you're writing in a
specific genre you know if i'm writing a
horror movie
and it doesn't have scary stuff in it
like that's going to be a failure
so i have to understand the genre i'm
working in and what the expectations of
my audience are
and i have to deliver that in a way that
feels fresh the audience is coming to
your movie with expectations of the
conventions of that genre they're going
to want to see
in the romantic comedy the mistaken
identity or the misheard thing or the
kiss at the end or whatever so how do
you deliver those things
without making them feel like boring and
cliched and well well trod right so
that's your challenge as a writer to um
to either embrace the conventions and
make them feel fresh or kind of subvert
them
i just watched a movie last week it's
not a great movie but it's it's good and
it's it's very like lovely um the
mitchells versus the machines on netflix
it's an animated movie um
and one thing they did at the ending
which i thought was really funny is you
know in the hero's journey the way that
they kind of combated this idea of like
and now this is gonna happen and now
this is gonna happen
what happens is you know in the hero's
journey in the climax when you're facing
off against the bad guy it looks like
you're gonna die oh no they died but
then they live
so what they did in the movie um
is um they face the robots you know and
the family's fighting and they they beat
the robots and it's like they destroy
the bad guy and it's like yay
but then the main character has fallen
into this pit
and the family gathers around it's like
oh my god katie no and it looks like
she's dead and she just pops up she goes
just kidding
they're mocking
that story moment
in the pharaoh's journey and so they're
acknowledging it and they're making fun
of it and we laugh and so there's ways
of embracing things at the same time
that you're kind of like going yeah i
know what i'm doing i know that that is
that moment i'm gonna have fun with it
um
so i think um
i think you have to um
i think you have to kind of find your
way
toward um
originality you know um
and you know some people say you know
there's
there's movies that don't you know
embody some sort of three-act structure
which is absolutely true
you know there are films that are mini
plot or anti-plot but the thing that
people have to understand is that mini
plot and anti-plot are a response to
arch plot which is three-act structure
they are responses to the classical form
okay so they take elements of three-act
structure and twist them and use them in
different ways so like in a mini plot
movie you might get all the information
you might get all this information
except what you're used to getting
in a normal movie so they're messing
with your expectations of information
that you get about the character or
the main character in the mini plot play
or the anti-plot play or movie
may not change
right but the audience has a shift has a
transformation so they're taking these
elements and turning them around you
know and using them in different ways
but in order to do that successfully you
have to actually understand arch plot
so for those of you are interested in
like
doing really cool weird things with
structure like just learn what classical
structure is and then you know think
about how you're subverting it or
playing with it or commenting on it
because
that's where really interesting stuff
starts to happen structurally
in dramatic storytelling
can you think of a movie that does that
that
yeah well tarantino does that all the
time you know like he plays around with
these conventions
of you know ways that we're normally
used to seeing movies and he just messes
with them he makes chapters he flips
time zones people are commenting we
circle back where are we
so he does a lot of fun with with
structure because he understands what
he's playing with
you know um if people are interested in
um
jim jarmisch also creates movies that
are um
um not the normal structure that we're
used to
um you know um but these are people who
are really doing
like
really cool experimental stuff but they
also understand
movies
all kinds of movies and that's why
they're so successful breaking the rules
and subverting you know the conventions
so yeah so that old adage before you can
break the rules you have to know the
rules that's right that's right i
believe that